mais c'est également rentable.
Il s'avère que le poisson est la protéine la plus rentable
sur Terre.
Si l'on regarde combien de protéines de poissons par dollar investi
comparé à toutes les autres sources de protéines animales,
le poisson est une bonne affaire.
De plus, il n'a pas besoin de terrain,
ce dont nous manquons,
comparé aux autres sources de protéines.
Et il n'a pas besoin de beaucoup d'eau douce.
Il consomme beaucoup moins d'eau douce
que, par exemple, le bétail
qui nécessite d'irriguer un champ
de manière à faire pousser de quoi le nourrir.
Le poisson a aussi une empreinte carbone très faible.
Il a une petite empreinte carbone
parce que nous devons aller en mer et attraper les poissons.
Ça nécessite un peu de carburant,
mais comme vous le savez, l'agriculture peut avoir une empreinte carbone,
et le poisson en a une notablement plus faible,
donc cela pollue moins.
Le poisson représente une partie importante de notre régime alimentaire
mais cette partie peut encore augmenter,
ce qui serait une bonne chose puisque nous savons
qu'il est bon pour notre santé.
Il peut réduire nos risques de cancer,
de maladie cardiaque et l'obésité.
En fait, notre PDG Andy Sharpeless,
qui est à l'origine de ce concept,
aime dire que le poisson est la protéine parfaite.
Andy parle aussi du fait que
le mouvement pour la conservation de nos océans a pris plus d'importance
que le mouvement pour la conservation du territoire,
et dans la conservation du territoire,
nous avons un problème
de conflit entre la biodiversité et la production alimentaire.
Il est nécessaire de détruire des forêts, habitats de la biodiversité,
pour avoir des champs
où faire pousser le maïs qui nourrit les gens.
Il y a donc constamment des réactions dans des sens opposés.
Il y a constamment une décision difficile à prendre entre
deux choses très importantes :
maintenir la biodiversité et nourrir la population.
Mais avec les océans, il n'y a pas cette guerre-là.
Dans les océans, la biodiversité n'est pas en guerre
avec l'abondance.
En fait, elles vont de pair.
Lorsque nous œuvrons pour la biodiversité,
nous obtenons l'abondance,
et c'est important dans l'optique de nourrir la population.
Cependant il y a un piège* (catch=pêche), quelqu'un a compris ? (Rires)
La pêche illégale.
La pêche illégale sape
la gestion durable des pêcheries dont je vous parle.
Ça concerne les poissons attrapés au moyen
de matériel qui a été interdit,
dans des endroits où la pêche est interdite,
les poissons qui ne sont pas de la bonne espèce ou du bon calibre.
La pêche illégale trompe le consommateur
et les honnêtes pêcheurs, ça doit prendre fin.
Les poissons issus de la pêche illégale sont commercialisés
au travers de la fraude aux produits de la mer.
Vous avez peut-être entendu parler de ceci.
La fraude aux produits de la mer désigne les poissons qui ont un label
qui ne leur correspond pas.
Pensez à la dernière fois où vous avez mangé du poisson.
Que mangiez-vous ?
Êtes-vous sûr de ce que c'était ?
Parce que nous avons testé 1300 échantillons différents de poisson
et environ un tiers n'étaient pas correctement labellisés.
Parmi les vivaneaux, 9 sur 10 n'en étaient pas.
59% du thon que nous avons testé
n'était pas correctement labellisé.
Nous avons testé 120 échantillons de rouget
et seulement 7 d'entre eux en étaient,
alors bonne chance pour trouver du rouget.
La chaîne d'approvisionnement des produits maritimes est très complexe
et à chaque étape de cette chaîne d'approvisionnement,
il y a une occasion pour de la fraude sur les produits de la mer,
à moins qu'il n'y ait traçabilité.
La traçabilité est un procédé permettant à l'industrie de la mer
de suivre à la trace des produits de la mer, du bateau à l'assiette,
afin d'être certain que le consommateur puisse se renseigner
sur la provenance des produits.
C'est une chose vraiment importante.
Ça a été fait par certains dans l'industrie, mais pas par assez,
donc nous amenons une loi devant le Congrès
appelée Traité de sûreté des produits de la mer
et je suis très excitée aujourd'hui d'annoncer la publication
d'une pétition de chefs, que 450 chefs
ont signée pour appeler le Congrès
à encourager le Traité de sûreté des produits de la mer.
Ça implique beaucoup de chefs célèbres que vous connaissez peut-être -
Anthony Bourdain, Mario Batali,
Barton Seaver et bien d'autres -
et ils ont signé la pétition parce qu'ils croient
que les gens ont le droit de savoir
ce qu'ils mangent.
(Applaudissements)
Les pêcheurs apprécient ce Traité, il y a donc une bonne chance
que nous ayons le soutien nécessaire
à faire passer cette loi
et c'est un moment crucial,
parce que c'est de cette façon que nous arrêtons la fraude aux fruits de mer,
que nous freinons la pêche illégale,
et que nous nous assurons que
des quotas, la protection de l'habitat,
et une diminution des prises accessoires
accomplissent le travail dont elles sont capables.
Nous savons que nous pouvons gérer durablement nos pêcheries.
Nous savons que nous pouvons produire
des repas équilibrés pour des centaines de millions de personnes
en n'ayant besoin ni de territoire, ni de beaucoup d'eau douce,
en ayant une empreinte carbone faible,
et en étant rentable.
Nous savons que sauver les océans
peut permettre de nourrir le monde,
et nous devons commencer maintenant.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.